[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
jetzt zur etwa zeit liebe ich einfach
erdbeer rezepte ich meine ich witze auch
machen wenn das ganze jahr über geben
würde gibt es leider noch nicht
aber hier habe ich jetzt ein richtig
tolles rezept mit baiser eine art pc
rolle der wirklich super einfach
herstellen könnt ihr könnt ja auch toll
vorbereiten zumindest die platte und
dann wenn ihr die torte verzehren wollt
also servieren wollt dann könnt ihr sie
einfach auf rollen ich starte jetzt
direkt mit der bc masse und sage euch
die zutaten für die wm asse nämlich fünf
eiweiß eine prise salz 250 gramm zucker
und lebensmittel verpasste im rot und
rosa gebe ich das eiweiß in eine saubere
und fettfreie rührschüssel wenn nämlich
fest dran kommt oder auch ein bisschen
eigelb kann man das eiweiß steif
schlagen jetzt einfach mit der prise
salz steif schlagen
[Musik]
es gebe ich hier langsam den zucker dazu
und höre dann die masse bei höchster
stufe weitere fünf bis zehn minuten bis
sie richtig schön ist und wirklich ganz
ganz festungsstadt ist und in der
römerzeit löst sich dann auch der zucker
auf und da könnte dann den finger test
machen
könig maschine ausschalten ein bisschen
schnee zwischen die finger nehmen und
wenn ihr dann keine zuckerkristalle mehr
zwischen den fingern spürt dann ist die
these richtig
[Musik]
die zuckerkristalle sind nicht mehr zu
spüren also ist die besemer jetzt
perfekt mit mach ich hier gleich einen
farbverlauf zuerst nämlich jetzt hier
ein drittel raus jetzt direkt auf meine
back folie der rest wird jetzt
eingefärbt einfach eine fahrstufe
dunkler also ein leichtes rosa dann
nehme ich jetzt die verpasste und keine
flüssigen farben nimmt in flüssige
farben die verändern die konsistenz der
bc massen auch von teigen und cremes zu
arg daher nehme ich immer verpassten
dann vorsichtig ein drin das ist jetzt
der zweite farbton dann noch mal ein
bisschen rosa und etwas rot dazu geben
für den dunkelsten farbton
[Musik]
mit den farben müsste wirklich sparsam
dosieren
sie sehen jetzt zwar noch ziemlich hell
aus aber durchaus packen werden die
weggenommen bisschen dunkler
da sieht man die farbe einfach etwas
deutlicher weil daneben die eismasse
trocknet jetzt hier vorsichtig verteilen
[Musik]
dann auch einmal so drüber streichen
damit wirklich ein schöner farbverlauf
wird
und so kommt jetzt die bg platte bei 180
grad ober unterhitze erstmal in den
backofen dann stelle ich den backofen
herunter und lasst ihr da nochmal weiter
backen
[Musik]
jetzt ist die platte fertig jetzt lege
ich dir ein sauberes geschirr doch drauf
dann einen tort marita und dann kann ich
jetzt die platte stürzen
so vorsichtig die folie abziehen und
dann einfach mit einem sauberen
geschirrtuch abdecken und die platte
schön abkühlen lassen
die b c klasse ist jetzt abgekühlt hatte
es ja auch mit einem tuch abgedeckt
jetzt kann ich die creme zu bereiten und
da mache ich eine maske ab ohne sahne
creme ohne puderzucker weil er wirklich
auch der zucker aus der bc platte schon
ausreicht dafür verwende ich 250 gramm
was capone etwas vanille extrakt 500
gramm sahne zum steifen etwas sonderbar
und für die füllung noch frische
erdbeeren die app dann habe ich jetzt
bereits fein gewürfelt
jetzt stelle ich zuerst einmal die creme
her
also kommt die mascarpone hier in einer
schüssel dann etwas man den extrakt dazu
kurz berühren
kommen jetzt langsam die sahne dazu
wirklich schön langsam damit die
mascarpone nicht blockt und nicht
stimmig bleibt also stück für stück
zufügen schönfärben sowie die mascarpone
immer weicher
[Musik]
wenn sich alles gut verbunden und habe
es nämlich sein vater zu einem schlag
ist die creme steigt und wenn die
sonderfahrt weg lasst und die creme so
schlag ist sie zwar nicht so lange stand
fest aber sie ist dann komplett konnten
freuen
[Musik]
so jetzt kommt die creme hier auf die
rückseite der rolle und ein drittel
ungefähr lasse ich übrig für die deko
und die verstreiche ich jetzt hier das
unten aber hier so einen kleinen rand
damit nichts raus gewählt
[Musik]
da kommen jetzt die etwa darauf die
gestückelten ihr könnt natürlich auch
andere früchte nehmen aber erst beim
passen momentan ganz gut
rapids hier die lambada angenommen also
die ganz voll fruchtigen automatischen
falls er erdbeeren länger aufhält
solltet ihr immer die andere sorte
nehmen die clary die rolle werden wir
sowieso heute essen
von daher passt das mit der sorte ganz
gut die ist nämlich vollautomatisch wird
aber auch schneller matschig aber heute
wird er alles gegessen und jetzt
vorsichtig auf rollen sich schwieriger
als jetzt meiner biscuit platte und ich
hole jetzt so dass praktisch das rot im
inneren bleibt und der rolle außen jetzt
immer heller wird
[Musik]
doch wirklich jetzt noch drüber und da
stelle ich sie kurz in den kühlschrank
und dann können wir sie gleich fertig
dekorieren und servieren fertig
dekoriert
ich habe die übrige creme in einen
spritzbeutel gefüllt mit einer großen
stern tülle und damit mache ich jetzt
tot von auf die torte spricht sich
einfach immer nach vorne und wieder
zurück um so eine welle zu machen
[Musik]
da kommt jetzt glitzer schnee drauf rosa
oder silber wer sagt rosa heide okay es
wurde abgestimmt wenn ich beides und gc
hat den vorteil dass er nicht schmilzt
auch auf feuchtem untergrund nicht als
auch auf der creme nicht bleibt schön
stabil ist nicht so süß und sieht schön
aus weiß glitzert
[Musik]
und da kommen jetzt einfach noch
halbierte erdbeeren drauf und fertig
[Musik]
wo gefällt sie mir richtig gut und jetzt
wollte ich jemanden zum probieren
[Musik]
ich finde ihnen es ist echt gut gelungen
das war echt diese schöne rote spirale
hat die nach außen weiß wird und jetzt
kommt unser ziel waren spezialist sie
das probieren eine erdbeer bowle sieht
irgendwie kalt aus kiel aus ja wieso
neues ich sag doch er kennt sich aus
das große stück also weiter innen sie
noch die erdbahn hat jetzt das handstück
probiert aber er tastet sich von außen
maria schrieb die songs und das wird im
moment arbeite eigentlich hier
es tut mir leid meine zuschauer wollen
halt immer so viele rezepte und ihr
leidet darunter
hier profitieren da schmeckt aber die
sache nicht so süß wie soll man so will
das ist immer so perfekt vor dem dem dt
ich glaube dass bse oder die vier
semester ist die platte so gut also muss
nicht schnell essen
lass dir zeit öffnen oder nicht ob das
so einfach verlauf macht so mit
lebensmittelfarbe und dann ist die rolle
von innen nach außen von dunkel nachher
cool oder aber ich glaube wenn man das
nur weiß gelassen hätte dann hätte man
hier innen einfach eine weiße masse und
wird es gar nicht sehen das ist meine
rolle ist daher perfekt
ich suche ja überall die wunde sagen ich
bin nur so kleine wer keinen hat so
etwas anderes ich suche dich überall ist
nach heimischer sicht der schulter
strategen erst hierher gekommen bist
schönemoor akustik im regen versteht und
stehen in der packung muss ausprobieren
und falls sie auch in den genuss dieser
pc rolle kommen wollt dann probiert sie
gerne mal aus edisons blogs
kannst du mir aber kein problem also bis
zum nächsten mal
findet ihr es eigentlich besser wenn
murat verkostet oder wenn die bank
verluste schreibe es in die kommentare
robin alle und können schreibt es mal
gerne rein oder frank
[Musik]